the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so last week we've learned how to
do triple integrals in rectangular and
cylindrical coordinates and now we have
to learn about spherical coordinates
which you will see a lot of fun
so what's the idea of spherical
coordinates where you're going to
represent a point in space using the
distance to the origin and two angles so
in a way you know you can think of these
as space analog of polar coordinates
because you just use distance to the
origin and then you have to use angles
to determine in which direction you're
going so somehow they're more polar than
cylindrical coordinates so how do we do
that so let's say that you have a point
in space at coordinates XYZ then instead
of using X Y Z you will use well one
thing you will use is the distance from
the origin and that is denoted by the
Greek letter Rho which looks like a
curly P but actually it's a Greek R so
that's a distance from the origin and so
that can take values anywhere between 0
and infinity then we have to use two
other angles and so for that let me
actually draw the vertical half plane
that contains our point starting from
the z-axis ok so then we have two new
angles well one of them is not really
new one is new that fee is the angle
downward from the z axis and the other
one
theta is the angle counterclockwise from
the x-axis
okay so fee
let me do it better so there's two ways
to the whole litter fee by the way and I
recommend this one because it doesn't
look like a hole so that's you know
easier that's the angle that you have to
go down from the positive z-axis and so
that angle that is from zero when you're
on the z axis increases increases to PI
over two when you're in the XY plane all
the way to PI or 180 degrees when you're
on the negative z axis it doesn't go
beyond that so Z is always between zero
and pi and finally the last one theta is
just going to be the same as before so
it's the angle after you project to the
XY plane that's the angle
counterclockwise from the x axis okay so
that's a little bit overwhelming not
just because of the new letters but also
because there's a lot of angles in there
so let me just try to you know suggest
two things that might help you a little
bit so one is you know these are called
spherical coordinates because if you fix
the value of ho then you're moving on a
sphere centered at the origin okay so
let's look at what happens on a sphere
centered at the origin so with equation
Rho equals a
well then fee measures how far self
you're going measures the distance from
the North Pole so if you've learned
about latitude and longitude in
geography well 3 and theta you can think
of as latitude and longitude except with
slightly different conventions okay so
fee is more or less the same thing as
latitude in the sense that it measures
how far north or south you are the only
difference is in geography latitude is
zero on the equator and becomes you know
something not something south depending
on how far you go from the equator here
you measure latitude starting from a
North Pole which is at zero increasing
all the way to the South Pole which is
at pi and theta you can think of as
longitude which measure measures how far
you are east or west
so the Greenwich meridian would be here
now the one on the x-axis that's the one
you use as the origin for longitude okay
now if you don't like geography here's
another way to think about it so
let's start again from cylindrical
coordinates which hopefully you're kind
of comfortable with now okay so you know
about cynical coordinates where we have
the Z coordinate state Z and in the XY
plane we do R and theta polar
coordinates and now let's think about
what happens when you slice things when
you look just at one of these vertical
planes containing the z axis so you have
a z axis and then you have the direction
away from the z axis which I will call
are just you know because that's what
our measures of course are goes all
around the z axis but I'm just doing a
slice for one of these vertical half
planes fixing the value of theta then of
course is a polar coordinate seen from
the point of view of the XY plane but
here it looks more like you have
rectangular coordinates again and so the
idea of spherical coordinates is you're
going to do polar coordinates again in
the RZ plane okay so if I have a point
in here then Rho will be the distance
from the origin and fee will be the
angle except it's measured from the
positive z axis not from the horizontal
axis but the idea in here see is what we
could write between quotes because I'm
not sure how correct that is but in a
way you can think of this as polar
coordinates in the Z plane so in
particular that's the key to
understanding how to switch between
cylindrical spherical coordinates and
cylindrical coordinates and then all the
way to X Y Z if you want right
because this picture here tells us how
to express Z and R in terms of Rho and
field so let's see how that works if I
project here here so this length is Z
but it's also whole times cosine fee
okay so I get Z equals Oh cuz fee and if
I look at our it's the same thing but on
the other side so R will be a whole sine
fee okay so you can use this to switch
back and forth between spherical and
cylindrical and of course if you
remember what x and y we're in terms of
R and theta
you can also keep doing this to figure
out oops so x is r cos theta that
becomes Rho sine Phi cos theta Y is a
sine theta so that becomes all sine V
sine theta and Z is Rho cos fee but
basically you don't really need to
remember these formulas as long as you
remember you know how to express R in
terms of cosine fee and x equals R cos
theta so now of course we're going to
use vertical coordinates in situations
where we have a lot of symmetry and in
particular where the z axis plays a
special role actually that's the same
with cylindrical coordinates semicolon
circle coordinates are set up so that
the z axis plays a special role so that
means whenever you have a geometric
problem and you're not told how to
choose your coordinates it's probably
wiser to try to Center things on the z
axis that's where these coordinates are
the best adapted
okay and oh yeah in case you ever need
to switch backwards I just want to point
out so oh it is the square root of R
squared plus Z squared which means it's
the square root of x squared plus y
squared plus Z squared okay so that's
basically all the formulas about
spherical coordinates
okay any questions about that nope okay
let's see who had seen spidel
coordinates before just to see if it's
not very many so I'm sure for one of you
saw it twice that's quite okay okay so
let's just you know look quickly at
equations of certain things so as I've
said if I set how equals a that will be
just a sphere of radius a centered at
the origin more interesting things let's
say give you V equals PI over 4 what do
you think that looks like actually let's
take a quick poll on things
okay yeah everyone seems to be saying
it's a cone and that's indeed the
correct answer so how do we see that
well we remember fear is the angle
downward from the z axis so let's say
that I'm going to look first at what
happens if I'm in the right half of a
plane of a blackboard so in the Y Z
plane then fee is my angle downward from
here so if I want to get PI over four
that's 45 degrees that means I'm going
to go diagonally like this of course if
I'm in the left half of a plane of a
blackboard it's going to be the same I
also take PI over four and I get the
other half and because the equation does
not involve theta it's all the same if I
rotate my vertical plane around the z
axis so I get the same picture in any of
these vertical half planes actually now
so this is V equals PI over four and
just in case to point out to you what's
going on when V equals PI over four
cosine and sine are equal to each other
above 1 over 2 so you can find again the
equation of this thing in cinah local
coordinates which i remind you was Z
equals R okay in general fee equal some
given number of Z equals some number
times R that will be a cone centered on
the z axis okay a special case what if I
say Phi equals PI over 2 yeah it's just
going to be the xy-plane
okay that's the flattest of all cones
okay so V equals PI over 2 it's going to
be just the xy-plane and in general if V
is less than PI over 2 when you're in
the upper half space if a is fee is more
than PI over 2 you'll be in the lower
half space okay
so that's pretty much all we need to
know at this point so what's next
well remember we were trying to do
triple integrals so now we are going to
do triple integrals in spherical
coordinates and for that we first need
to understand what the volume element is
what will be DV
okay so DV will be something D Rho D Phi
D theta or in any order that you want
but this one is usually the most
convenient so to find out what it is
well we should look at how we are going
to be slicing things now okay so if you
integrate D Rho D Phi D theta it means
that you're actually slicing your solid
into little pieces
that live somehow you know if you set an
interval of holes okay sorry
maybe I should so if you first integrate
over hole it means that you will
actually choose first a direction from
the origin given by V and theta and in
that direction you will try to figure
out how far does your region extend and
of course how far that goes might depend
on fee and theta then you will vary fee
so you have to know for a given value of
theta how far down does your solid
extend and finally the value of theta
will correspond to you know in which
directions 400 z-axes do we go so we're
going to see that on examples but before
we can do that we need to get the volume
element and so what I would like to
suggest is that we need to figure out
what is the volume of a small piece of
solid which corresponds to a certain
change Delta ho Delta V and Delta Theta
so Delta ho means that you know you have
to connect concentric
fear spheres and you're looking at a
very French shell in between them and
then you'll be looking at a piece of
that spherical shell corresponding to
small values of Phi and theta
so because I'm stretching the limits of
my ability to draw on the world here's a
picture I'm going to try to reproduce
that on the board but so let's start by
looking just at what happens on a sphere
of radius a and let's try to figure out
the surface area element on the sphere
in terms of phi and theta and then we'll
add the whole direction okay so sorry
let me say let's start by understanding
surface area on a sphere of radius a so
that means we'll be looking at a little
piece of the sphere corresponding to
angles Delta V and in that direction
here Delta Theta okay so you know when
you draw a map of a world on a globe
that's exactly you know what the grid
lines found for you so what's the area
of this guy well of course all the sides
are curvy they are all on the sphere
none of them is straight but still if
it's small enough and it looks like a
rectangle so let's just try to figure
out what are the sides of your rectangle
okay so let's see well I think I need to
draw a bigger picture of this game
okay so this guy so that's a piece of
what's called the parallel in geography
okay that's a circle that goes east-west
so now this parallel is a circle of
radius well the radius is less than a
because you know if you're very close to
the North Pole it will be actually much
smaller so you know that's why when you
say that you're going around the world
it depends whether you do it at the
equator at the North Pole it's much
easier at the North Pole
so anyway okay so you know this is a
piece of a circle of ideas well the
radius is what I would call our because
that's the distance from the z-axis okay
that's actually pretty hard to see now
so if you can see it better on this one
then so this guy here this length is r
and r is just a hole well always a times
sine V and then we have this angle fee
in here to do some color so it's getting
very cluttered so we have this fee and
so R is going to be a whole sign fee but
always a so let me just put a sign fee
okay and the corresponding angle is
going to be measured by theta so the
length of this is going to be a sine Phi
Delta Theta
that's for this side now what about that
side the north south side
well if you're moving enough south it's
not like east-west you always have to go
all the way from the North Pole to the
South Pole so that's actually a great
circle a merriam of length well I mean
well the radius is the radius of a
sphere total length is two pi a so this
is a piece of a circle of radius a and
so now the length of this one is going
to be a Delta V okay so just to recap
this is a sine Phi Delta Theta and this
guy here is a Delta V so you can treat
it because it's
and so that tells us that if I take a
small piece of a sphere then its surface
area Delta s is going to be
approximately a sine Phi Delta Theta
times a delta fee which I'm going to
have like as a squared sine Phi Delta V
Delta Theta so what that means is say
that I want to integrate something just
on the surface of a sphere well I would
use C and theta as my coordinate and
then to know how big a piece of a sphere
is I would just take a squared sine Phi
D Phi D theta okay so that's the surface
element on a sphere and now what about
going back into the third dimension so
adding some depth to these things well
I'm not going to try to the whole
picture because you've seen that's
slightly tricky well let me try anyway
so - so you can have fun with my
completely unreadable diagrams so if you
look at now you know something that's a
bit like that piece of sphere but with
some thickness to it the thickness will
be Delta ho and so the volume will be
roughly the area of the thing on the
sphere times the thickness so I claim I
claim that we'll get basically the
volume element just by multiplying
things by D Rho so let's see that
so now if I have a sphere of radius hole
and another one that's slightly bigger
of radius Oh plus Delta ho and then I
have a little box in here then I know
that the volume of this thing will be
essentially well its thickness the
thickness is going to be Delta ho times
the array of its base or top doesn't
really matter which is what we've called
Delta s okay so we'll get is side a
becomes all now square sine V Delta
Delta V Delta Theta and so out of that
we get the volume element in spherical
coordinates which is all squared sine
Phi D Rho D Phi D theta and that's a
formula that you should remember okay so
whenever we integrate a function and we
decide to switch to polar to vertical
coordinates then DX dy DZ or our DRD
theta DZ will become a whole squared
sine Phi D Rho D Phi D theta okay any
questions on that okay so let's
let's see how that works so
as an example remember at the end of the
last lecture I try to set up an example
where we were looking at a sphere sliced
by a slanted plane and now we're going
to try to find the same volume of that
spherical cap again but using spherical
coordinates instead so I'm going to just
you know be smarter than last time so
last time we had set up these things
with a slanted plane that was cutting
things diagonally and you know if I just
want to find the volume of this cap then
maybe it makes more sense to all date
things so that my plane is actually
horizontal and things are going to be
centered in the z-axis so in I mean in
case you see that it's the same then
that's great if not then doesn't really
matter you can just think of this as a
new example so I'm going to try to find
the volume of a portion of the unit
sphere that lies above the horizontal
plane Z equals 1 over root 2 1 over root
2 was the distance from the origin to
our slanted plane so I've told you what
8 that's how you get this value it's not
very important you can just read that as
a new example if you want okay so we can
compute this in actually pretty much any
coordinate system and also of course we
can set up not only volume but you know
we can try to find the moment of inertia
about the central axis or all sorts of
things but in there doing volume for
simplicity so actually this would go
quite a well in cylindrical coordinates
but let's do it in spherical coordinates
because that's the topic of today a good
exercise do it in cylindrical and see if
you get the same thing so how do we do
that well we have to figure out how to
set up
our triple integral in spherical
coordinates so remember we'll be
integrating one divi divi will become a
whole squared sine Phi D Rho D Phi D
theta and now as we start we are already
facing some serious problem we want to
set up the bounds for hole for a given
fee and theta so that means we choose
latitude longitude we choose which
direction we want to aim for you know
which point of a sphere we want to aim
at and we are going to shoot away from
the origin towards this point and we
want to know what portion of the way is
in our solid so you know we are going to
choose a value of C and theta and we're
going to try to figure out what part of
our a is inside this solid so what
should be clear is at which point we
leave the solid right what's the value
of hole here it's just one the sphere is
all equals one that's pretty good
the question is where do we enter the
region so we enter the region when we go
for this plane and the plane is z equals
one over root two so what does that tell
us about hole well it tells us so
remember Z is all cosine fee so the
plane is Z equals 1 over root 2 that
means Rho cosine Phi is 1 over root 2
that means Rho equals 1 over root 2
cosine fee or as some of you know it 1
over root 2 times second fee okay so if
we want to set up the bounds they will
start
with one other hood to second fee all
the way to one now what's next well so
we've done you know I think that's
basically how the start of the job next
we have to figure out what's the range
for fee so the range for fee well we
have to figure out you know how far to
the north and to the south our region
goes well the lower bound for fee is
pretty easy right because we go all the
way to the North Pole direction so we
start at zero question is where does it
stop
find out where it stops we have to
figure out what is the value of fee when
we hit the edge of the region okay so
maybe you see it maybe you don't one way
to do it geometrically is to just you
know it's always great to draw a slice
of your region so if you slice these
things by a vertical plane or even
better with article half plane something
to delete one half of the picture you
know so I'm going to do all these are
and Z directions as before so my sphere
is here my plane is here at one over two
and my solid is here so now the question
is what's the value a fee when I'm going
to stop hitting the region and you know
if you try to figure out first what is
this direction here that's also 1 over 2
and so this is actually 45 degrees also
known as PI over 4 the other way to
think about it is at this point well o
is equal to 1 because you're on the
sphere but you're also on the plane so
Hocus fee is 1 over root 2 so if you
plug how equals 1 into here you get cos
V equals 1 over 2 we
gives you V equals PI over four that's
the other way to do it you can do it
either by calculation or by looking at
the picture so either way we've decided
that fee goes from zero to PI over four
so this is PI over four finally what
about theta well because we go all
around the z-axis we're going to go just
zero to two pi okay any questions about
these mounts okay
so note how the equation of this
horizontal plane in the spherical
coordinate has become a little bit weird
but if you remember how we do things say
that you have a line in polar
coordinates and that line does not pass
for the origin then you also end up with
something like that you get something
like R equals a second theta or a
cosecant theta for horizontal or
vertical lines and so you know it's not
surprising you should get this that's in
line with the idea that we are just
doing again polar coordinates in the RZ
directions so of course in general
things can be very messy but generally
speaking the kinds of regions that we'll
be setting up things for are no more
complicated or no less complicated than
what we would do in the plane in polar
coordinates
okay so there's you know a small list of
things that you should know how to set
up but you won't have some really really
strange thing
yes the oh you mean the bounce fellow
yes so in the inner integral we are
going to fix values of Phi and theta so
that means we fix in advance a direction
in which we are going to shoot away from
the origin so now as we shoot this way
we are going to hit our region somewhere
and we are going to exit again somewhere
else okay so first of all we have to
figure out where we enter where we leave
while we enter when the ray hits the
flat face when we hit the plane and we
will leave when we hit the sphere so the
lower bound will be given by the plane
the upper bound will be given by the
sphere okay so now you have to get
spherical coordinates equations for both
the plane and the sphere for the sphere
that's easy that's four equals one for
the plane you start with Z equals 1 over
2 and you switch it into struggle
coordinate and when you solve for hole
and that's how you get these mounts that
okay alright so that's the setup part
and of course the evaluation part goes
as usual
and since I'm running short of time I'm
not going to actually do the evaluation
I'm going to let you figure out how it
goes let me just say in case you want to
check your answers so at the end you get
2 PI over 3 minus 5 PI over 6
oh yes it looks quite complicated that's
basically because you get 1 over well
you get a second square when you
integrate C when you integrate 4 squared
you will get a whole cubed over 3
but that whole cube will give you a
second cube of a lower bound and then
when you integrate sine fee second cube
fee you do a substitution you see that
integrates to one of our sequence one of
the second so it's second square with a
factor in front so in the second Square
when you plug in no that's not quite all
of it
yeah well the second square is one thing
and also your the other bound you get
sine fee which integrates to cosign fee
so you get anyway lots of things ok
enough about it so next I have to tell
you about applications and of course
well there's the same applications that
we've seen last time finding volumes
finding messes finding average values of
functions in particular now if it says
you know find the average distance of a
point in this solid to the origin
well spherical coordinates become
appealing because the function you're a
virgin is just Oh while in other
coordinate systems it's a more
complicated function so you know if
you're asked to find the average
distance from the origin struggle
coordinates can be interesting also well
does moments of inertia probably the one
about the z axis because you know if you
have to integrate something that
involves X or Y then your integrand will
contain that awful Oh sine Phi sine Phi
cosine V cosine theta and then it won't
be much fun to evaluate so but anyway it
has the usual ones and then there's a
new one so in physics you've probably
seen things about gravitational
attraction if not well it's what causes
apples to fall and other things like
that as well
so anyway physics tells you that if you
have two masses then they attract each
other with a force that's directed
toward each other and in intensity is
proportional to the two masses and
inversely proportional to the square of
a distance between them so if you have
you know a given solid with a certain
mass distribution and you want to know
how it attracts something else that you
will put nearby then you actually have
to you know the first approximation
would be to just say well let's just put
a point mass at its center of mass but
if your solid is actually not
homogeneous or has weird shape then
that's not actually the exact answer so
in general you would have to just take
every single piece of your object and
figure out how it attracts you and then
you know compute the sum of these so for
example if you want to understand you
know why anything that you drop in this
form will fall down you have to
understand that you know Burstyn is
actually attracting it towards Boston
and some of it is attracting it towards
Somerville and lots of things like that
and China which is much further on the
other side is going to attract it
towards China but that's a lot of stuff
on the other side of the earth and so
overall it's supposed to end up just
going down okay so now how to find this
out well you have to just integrate over
the entire earth
okay so let's try to see how that goes
so so the setup that's going to be
easiest for us to do computations is
going to be that you know we are going
to be the test mess that's going to be
falling and we're going to put ourselves
at the origin and the solid that's going
to attract us is going to be you know
wherever we want in space you'll see
putting yourself at the origin is going
to be better well you have to put
something at the origin and you know the
one that will stay a point mass I mean
make is I'm not really 0.2 but anyway
let's say that I'm a point and when I
have a solid attracting me well so then
if I take a small piece of it with a
mass Delta M then that portion of the
solid exerts a force on me which is
going to be directed towards it and will
have intensity so let's see so the
gravitational force exerted by a mass
Delta M at a point of XYZ in space on a
mass M at the origin well we know how to
express that physics tells us that the
magnitude of this force is going to be
well G is just a constant okay it's the
gravitational constant and its value
depends on which unit system you use
usually is pretty small times the mass
Delta M times the test mass little m
divided by the square of the distance
and the distance from you - that thing
is conveniently called ho since we've
been introducing spherical coordinates
so that's the size that's a magnitude of
the force but we also need to know that
this the direction of the force and the
direction is going to be two
world's bad point so the direction of a
force is going to be that of X Y Z but
if I want a unit vector of a knife of
scale this down to length one so let me
divide this by a hole to get a unit
vector
so that means that the first I'm getting
from this guy is actually going to be G
Delta M M over whole cubed times X Y Z
I'm just multiplying the magnitude by
the unit vector in the correct direction
okay so now if I have not just that
little piece Delta M but an entire solid
then I have to sum all these guys
together and I will get a vector that
gives me the total force exerted okay so
of course there's actually three
different calculations in one because
you know you have to sum the X
components to get the X component of the
total force same with a y and same with
the Z so if you look just say adver well
let me first write down the actual
formula so if you integrate over the
entire solid oh and they have to remind
you well what's the mass Delta M of a
small piece of volume Delta V well it's
the density times the volume so the mass
is going to be so it densities Delta so
lot of Greek letters well times the
volume element so you will get that the
force is the triple integral over your
salad of G M XYZ of a whole cubed Delta
DV now two observations about that so
the first one well of course these are
just constants so they can go out the
second observation so here we are
integrating a vector quantity so what
does that mean I just mean the X
component of a force is given by
integrating GM X of a whole cubed Delta
DV
the y-component same with why the
z-component same thing with Z okay
there's no like you know it just
integrate component by component to get
each component of the force so now we
could very well do this in rectangular
coordinates if we want but the annoying
thing is with whole cubed co cubed is
going to be x squared plus y squared
plus Z squared to the three-halves
that's not going to be very pleasant
thing to integrate so it's much better
to set up these integrals in spherical
coordinates and if we are doing to do it
in spherical coordinates if we're going
to do it in special coordinates then
probably we don't want to bother too
much with x and y components because
those would be unpleasant it would give
us locus V so a whole sine Phi cos theta
of sine theta so the actual we will set
up things something that is to place the
solid so that the z axis is an axis of
symmetry and of course that only works
if the solid has some axis of symmetry
you know like if you're trying to find
the gravitational attraction of I don't
know the Pyramid of Giza then you won't
be able to set it up so that it has a
rotation symmetry well that's a tough
fact of life and you have to actually do
it in X Y Z coordinate but if at all
possible then you're going to place
things well I guess even when you could
Center it on the z axis but anyways
you're going to mostly place things so
that your solid is actually centered on
the z axis and what you gain by that
well what you gain by that is but that
by symmetry the gravitational force will
be directed towards you know along the z
axis so you'll just have to figure out
the Z component
so then the first will be actually you
know in advance that it will be given by
zero zero and some z-component and when
you just need to compute that component
and that component will be just G times
M times triple integral of Z over Rho
cubed Delta D D okay so that's the first
simplification we can try to do the
second thing is where we have to choose
our favorite coordinate system to do
this but I claim that actually spherical
coordinates are the best
because let's see what happens so G
times mass times triple integral Z well
as in spherical coordinates becomes Rho
cosine fee over whole cubed density well
we can't do anything about density and
then DV becomes whole squared sine Phi D
Rho D Phi D theta well so what happens
with that well you see that you have a
whole whole squared and a whole cube
that cancel each other so in fact it
simplifies quite a bit if you do it in
spherical coordinates
so the Z component of a force so I'm
putting the Z here to remind you it's
the Z component that is not a partial
derivative okay don't get things mixed
up just a Z component of the force
becomes GM triple integral of Delta cos
V sine Phi D Rho D Phi D theta and so
this thing is not DV of course DV is
much bigger but we've somehow canceled
out most of DV with stuff that was in
the integrand and see that's actually
suddenly much less scary
okay so just you know to give you an
example of what you can prove in this
way you can prove Newton's theorem which
says the following thing it says the
gravitational attraction of a spherical
planet of a spherical planet if you'd
say with uniform density actually it's
enough of a density to depend just on
distance to the center but let me just
simplify the statement
is equal to that of a point mass with
the same total mass at its center okay
so what that means is that you know so
the way we would set it up is you would
be sitting here and your planet would be
over here or if you are the surface of
it then of course you would just put it
you know tangent to the XY plane here
and you would compute that quantity
computation is a little bit annoying if
the sphere is sitting up there because
of course you have to find bounds and
that's not going to be that I pleasant
the case but we actually know how to do
fairly well is if your interests at the
surface of the planet but then what the
theorem says is that the force that
you're going to feel is exactly the same
as if you removed all of the planet and
you just put an equivalent point mass
here so if the earth collapse to a black
hole at the center of the earth with the
same mass well you wouldn't notice the
difference immediately on whether you
would but at least not in terms of your
weight okay let's me and for today